CREW
Action.
RON
I go into like a goat phase, upon orgasm.
KYLA
That’s normal, baby.
RON
It’s like, oh, oh, eee aweee!
(LAUGHING)
Aweeee!
RON
Look at us, all together again.
LIL REL HOWERY
The casting for this is amazing.
We all really became friends.
I was like in tears.
We were laughing every take.
JOHN CENA
Everyone’s so professional.
YVONNE ORJI
Wa-wai-wai-wai-wait.
(CENSORED CURSING)
JOHN CENA
Whoes idea was it to bring back Maurillio?
MAURILLIO
Wait, what?
(LAUGHING)
YVONNE ORJI
We have new characters added.
We have Steve Buscemi that we get to play off.
KYLA
Dad!
REESE
Perfect timing, right?
STEVE BUSCEMI
There’s a lot of improvising.
MARCUS
I’m going to jail forever!
They gon make my grandkids go to jail!
(LAUGHING)
MARCUS
Everybody going to jail!
(LAUGHING)
JOHN CENA
It’s kinda like WWE, you just riff off of each other.
MEREDITH HAGNER
More! More! More!
(LAUGHING)
STEVE BUSCEMI
There’s a baby involved now.
CREW
Fake baby, kinda creepy.
KYLA
He’s crawling.
MARCUS
Maybe a grown baby. Maybe an adult.
We’re gonna adopt an adult.
Make em work around the house...
(LAUGHING)
RON
You didn’t know!
Now you do!
YVONNE ORJI
There’s gotta be some action!
MARCUS
What the...
(GUNSHOTS)
LIL REL HOWERY
John drove the car for real.
MEREDITH HAGNER
Ahhh!
YVONNE ORJI
Flights!
LIL REL HOWERY
Broke the plane!
JOHN CENA
It’s a fun ride.
LIL REL HOWERY
And it’s big!
MEREDITH HAGNER
Wooo!
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
JOHN CENA
The probability is about as slim
as this take being in the movie.
(LAUGHING)